you
hi everyone is Gerry this is a round
three game from the 2015 Sinquefield Cup
between Magnus Carlsen playing on the
white end and Maxine viola Grove let's
dive right in what happened in this one
an English opening on board both sides
with a king side fianchetto d4 cd19
castles Knight c3 okay let's take a
moment to breathe here what to do move
seven how exactly to complete
development on the black side many
options here in the game it was Queen c7
and after 95 Queen takes C now with this
move sequence Queen c7 95 and now this
last move Queen takes c4 how to describe
this what is black basically saying here
in plain English what's black saying
black is saying I'm content with playing
a position type where I have a
structural defect and I give my opponent
the bishop pair in exchange for having a
slight lead in development and I won't
be fighting against some space
disadvantage okay that was a mouthful
let's get some moves on the board Knight
takes a [ __ ] up this is what I'm
referring to this is the line this is
what happened in the game
grab the pawn on e and here's your
structural defect this is an isolated d7
pond he's vulnerable it's not easily
protected and black has a space a bit
skewed me not a space avenge a lead time
wise only one move away before he's
fully developed before there's a
connection between those rooks also
there is no white pawn in blacks
position nor is there even a white pawn
on the fourth rank that is somehow
cramping the black development
development is a little bit more smooth
so these are some of the pros and cons
that were that we have on deck here
not the only approach as mentioned many
approaches here this is the one that was
picked in the game Queen c7 I'd like to
just highlight one maybe two more very
quickly the knight c6 you know if that's
not you know if you kind of cringe if
you're playing in the black side
especially you know if you're the
positional type player a positional
player they like have a nice harmonious
structures I'm more of that type and
that really wouldn't be so appealing to
me on the black side to play a structure
like that but however you slice it black
white will have some advantage in some
way there will be some position type
that will be favorable to the white side
let's say after castles here how how
exactly to get this bishop out now you
have to move one of these two but
there's no pressure on the knight do you
take here this speeds up this gives a
slight time edge here for the white side
developing a piece like this moving that
Knight twice you could go in for that
and follow up keeping a nice structure
but time maybe not on your side as much
more space for white c4 pun there's even
let's say the move Queen a5 let's just
put this on board Queen a5 the Queen
coming over here c5 just go a little bit
further there's there's lines like this
where in the end white is still having
something in this case two bishops
breathing down the Queen side maybe F 45
at some point Knight see Knight c5
tremendous square for a knight quite
possibly yeah so many many different
options
let me just even throw out one more at
this point after knight c6 Castle
there's even a gambit line maybe you're
more of the tactical player okay you're
fine with giving up a pawn because in
this position black has maybe some
compensation
I don't know full compensation but some
compensation in the form of Queen side
pressure against white they're down upon
but here we have the rook the bishop
converging on b2 watch out Bishop f5
here comes a rook
and get the idea many different position
types what do we have on board this one
here okay let's get some more moves in
castles knight c6 what do we do take the
knight repair the structure definitely
not Bishop e3 Knight g4 so this bishop
pair by the way is short-lived
when white goes in for this yeah so I
mean Bishop e3 Knight g4 is basically
forcing White's hand this Knight is it
too many times you cannot be you cannot
maintain the knight on d4 so Knight c2
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
Queen e7 so something was something
changed there we had a knight for Bishop
exchange so it's no longer Bishop pair
type advantage position we might start
to our I might start to look in this
position towards okay we have the bishop
pair on board or excuse me not the
bishop pair opposite color bishops but
what still remains in the position what
is still standing out here just passing
by and looking at a game like this what
jumps out to you for me it's it's the
structure that's the main difference in
this game here playing against the d7
pawn playing against the black structure
okay Knight d5 improving his position
nice central post this is an isolated
pond squares in front of it act as
excellent homes and this is really can't
ask for a better home for a night Bishop
takes v2 and there goes blacks be pond
so the B pawns are exchanged one pair of
rooks are exchanged and now III rook b2
a4 and black is now challenging the
strong Knight
White says not so fast I don't want to
allow the knight exchange and enter an
opposite color Bishop ending I don't
want to tend towards let's just say I
don't want to tend towards
a position that is maybe simplifying a
little bit too much where we have an
opposite colored bishop ending in the
game it was Knight f4 and this move
ensures that there will be another
imbalance struck in the position a
knight for a bishop exchange will occur
the queen is it in the game it was
Bishop takes Knight if you don't take
the knight if you do something else such
as Queen here there is Knight d3 with a
fork so again however you slice it the
bishop for a knight exchange will occur
and this would actually be terrible of
Queen d6 Knight d3 rook here and you're
not only getting the bishop but there
goes that vulnerable pawn so black
recognizes this Knight d3 move and says
well I'm going to at least double your
pawns Bishop takes Knight how to take
what would you do here quick pop quiz if
you'd like pause the video how would you
recapture an f4 okay in the game
it was a takes F the computer will cite
both G takes and he takes but for a
human player e takes is the better of
the two keeping a nice structure nice
compact structure keeping your Jeep on
on board computer has no will suffer no
anxiety but a human player will start to
maybe become a little bit anxious of
moves like Knight H for deserting
pressure on these squares here at some
point maybe so just to rule out stuff
like that it takes f4 nice structure one
of the drawbacks you might see this
well you might view this as well when I
take like this now I've given black this
past pawn this should not be really
entering your thought process it should
not be viewed that this pawn is all of a
sudden dangerous maybe for some viewers
seeing a capture like this they they
might think like that but this pawn is
long way off a very long way off from
posing any serious threat to the white
side black has their own worries mind
you I've referenced already the deep on
the deep hunt is weak but after we have
this exchange here after Bishop for
night exchange this is another big deal
this is another big shift in the game
and imbalance a knight for Bishop
imbalance dark square weaknesses is
maybe the most concise way to describe
the position now f6 and h6 there isn't a
dark square Bishop to remedy these
weakened squares which means that the
King shelter if we look at each sides
the the homes for each side's King who
has the better home who is safer it is
without a doubt the white side this is a
fantastic structure and it is
complemented very well by having the
light square bishop around to watch over
these squares black on the other hand
does not have that dark square bishop
and so he will need to take good care of
his dark squares here allowing a queen
to get on this diagonal would not only
be you know first and foremost with
check but or a long term it controls it
controls this g7 square which is blacks
flight square combine that with the rook
getting down here and you're starting to
face making one threats black has to be
very careful deficient pond a weakened
King position white again a perfectly
harmonious King position a very well
complemented structure regarding the
pawns and Bishop pawns control dark the
bishops here around to watch over the
light okay Queen b6 shouldn't be too
surprising you don't want to allow Queen
d4 this is a fantastic diagonal on top
of this Queen b7
is not just offensive it's saying I'm
not going to allow you to activate your
rook so easily I'm going to maintain
some pressure on f2 ok what does white
do he tries to disrupt this coordination
on f2 free pawn right not so fast
Queen d4 you rook his gun Queen c5 still
maintaining control over d4 Queen takes
D what other option might there have
been here dropping d7 right now if Queen
b5 there's Queen d4 King g8 and now
Queen takes a 7 this to be perfectly
honest would have been pretty
interesting I know that this is now a
passed pawn but he will be hunted down
after rook a to rook d1 Queen takes a 5
I don't know that white would go in for
a queen exchange here and the reason I
say this is because if we have the
Queen's come off we have a position
where black clearly down upon but the
Queen side is now not so relevant
there aren't pawns on both wings of the
board so something a little something is
lost with this idea of the superior
minor piece the bishop being better than
the night if one section of the board
one side of the board the Queen side in
this case is a bit irrelevant you know
not much is going to happen on the Queen
side pawns are not on both wings the
bishop loses something the knight will
have a better time working on just one
sector of the board his short-range nest
say you know is not as much a liability
if we're working with just one side of
the board just King side pawns alone
again as mentioned I don't know if this
would have happened in the game if at
this point again Queen b5
at this point here Queen b5 was played
instead of the games move Queen C set c5
just to have this check King here and
then take here I don't know if white
would really go for a queen exchange
maybe keeping the Queen's on the board
is the more human approach you don't see
it but the computer evaluation has this
variation in the one where the Queen's
are off as roughly the same but I think
recognizing you know White has the safer
King it makes a little bit more sense to
keep the most powerful piece on board
the Queen
it's another factor another piece of you
know another piece of criteria to look
into to help make better decisions in
the chess game I'll have the safer King
position I'm gonna keep the Queen's on
the board she's gonna give you a problem
at some point or at least I hope so
okay let's get back to the actual game
Queen c5 Queen takes Steve rook a to so
trying to hunt that pawn down Queen d3
you know when I'm reviewing for these
games certain moves I can't really make
sense of them I have to I have to really
think I have the help of a computer but
sometimes the computer isn't so helpful
and it wasn't until I really stared at
this position right here that I started
to recognize the deeper plans or what I
think at least were some of the deeper
ideas that the players had I could be
completely off but I'm going to share
them nevertheless Queen to d3 not quite
again initially I'm not quite sure what
it was doing this is here's what here
are a couple of things I can say white
is offering for one he's giving up this
pawn if black wants to take it he could
take it but he's going to release the
pressure on f2 and as soon as that
pressure is released white is going to
be able to reorganize his pieces this
rook who's been sitting enough
one four four forever since castling
since move whatever move eleven he's he
can now finally breathe he could do
something a bit more productive if black
does not take this pawn and he doesn't
in the game if he doesn't take the pawn
the pawn plays to a six and will be
secured by the Queen and soon thereafter
it will be the bishop will have a little
bit of a changing of the guard of that
a6 pawn the vicious will defend the pawn
and a six and the Queen will then be
freed up to do more queen like things be
a pest tack things defend things perform
multiple tasks be a queen in other words
so if this is like a now-or-never moment
with this queen d3 move saying you could
take my pond right now if you don't I'm
gonna play a six and he will live that's
what happens in the game King g7 a six
the pond lives pawns remain another way
to view a pawns remain on both side of
both sides of the board so this night
for Bishop idea this Bishop still a
super powerful piece for as long as
these eight pawns are on board as soon
for as long as both sides of the board
the King side the Queen side the whole
chessboard is relevant the Bishop all
the more powerful when facing the night
now should you take the pawn let's have
a look at let's say rook takes instead
of this King g7 move the move played in
the game move 25 supposed rook takes
pawn this allows the move Queen a 7 now
there isn't no there isn't any fantastic
knockout but I just want to show you how
white it's a slow approach but it's a
slow slow and steady progress that could
be made here again as mentioned when
Queen d3 was played I couldn't make
sense of it
it's it's I believe a deep idea one
that's now going to slowly improve the
position of your pieces notice notice
after Queen d3 Queen e2 what is this
doing first and foremost it's saying
okay you're not getting to my second
ring so easily you're not going to be
putting pressure on f2 on top of that I
will maintain pressure on your
in doing so I'm placing a certain
restriction on your queen on c5 let's
get some more moves in here
rook b5 and now we could have the rook
getting activated rook to d1 let's say
King g7 at some point maybe the f7 pawn
could be vulnerable maybe you don't want
to allow the rook to enter your eighth
rank with check from here we could have
rook d7 another one another idea again
it's a slow approach but there are moves
like Bishop f3 this pawn is passed let's
say he gets rolling King g2 just having
some coordination here defending the
bishop
if this pawn continues to roll hang on
now there's already a big problem it's
completely lost for black the computer
reads it as + - all of a sudden if you
try to get too careless and say I have a
passed pawn I'm just going to push him
well hang on here's a rook d7 move and
just a highlight it's not the best of
course but just to show you how you
could be tactically vulnerable all of a
sudden King here there's already rook
takes the knight okay
within Queen takes rook this is a slow
untangling a slow regrouping that will
occur if black hunts down if black hunts
down the apon activating the rook
possibilities for back rank stuff
seventh-ranked stuff he's looking at
going after the black King additionally
do not forget about this idea of
breaking down the black King side
structure with h4 h4 h5 stuff
as mentioned rook d7 would be good here
but just to highlight certain structural
changes on the King's life because
that's where we only have pawns right
now h4 this is not best by any means I
just want to highlight certain
structural changes if h5 maybe at some
point f5 can play a role this Knight if
he's no longer there if there aren't
pieces
anymore watching over f5 this is a nice
way to break down a black pawn structure
and if h5 isn't played maybe this pond
one day gets here and takes away a
flight square from the black king so
this is a very slow approach it's a nice
little reorganization it did kick off it
started with this queen d3 again in the
game this Queen d3 move this is a
now-or-never moment you're gonna take
the pawn now or allow me to regroup well
in the game black said I'm not going to
allow you to regroup as easily I want to
maintain pressure on your f2 pawn king
g7 a6 the pawn lives h5 bishop b7 has
mentioned the Queen does not want to be
the one babysitting the pawn the bishop
fulfills that role perfectly great
coordination here he still mind you
watching over these light squares Knight
f5 Queen e5 a little bit of shifting
here Queen is defending both Bishop and
throwing a punch at the rook rook d2
Queen throws in a check and now we have
the bishop dropping back avoiding Knight
takes bishop stuff and then the Queen
let's say getting behind maintaining the
bishop probably better stated just
maintaining the bishop not allowing
night for Bishop exchange so Bishop g2
Knight f5 and now Queen to e5 so after a
little bit of maneuvering there we have
the offer of Queen exchange one that is
accepted Queen takes Queen
is there something better here computer
points out Queen d6 and Queen takes
there would be rook takes still an
advantage close to a pawn advantage even
though materials balanced here excuse me
it's not balanced it's just a pawn
advantage for white nothing healthiest
of pawns but it's more related this
advantage is more related to the knife
for Bishop imbalance on board
we didn't have Queen d6 it was Queen
takes Queen this straightens out the
white structure but black looks to hunt
that pawn down with rook to e2 and what
would you do here how to approach this
position if you'd like to pause the
video see what you come up with what
would you do is white in this position
okay might be tempting to play f4 just
securing your pawn but white gets on
with rook to b1 he's going straight
after that pawn on a 7 and having a past
a pawn
he is just so good you know especially
knowing that the bishop is already here
controlling that queening square it's a
big problem f4 if played would allow
Knight e3 and well you don't have so
many options you know what can you do
here if you play rook f2 this would be a
draw rook f2 allows rook e1 check bishop
here rook a1 and then on the next move
you're taking the bishop and then taking
the pawn that'll be pretty easy draw to
hold at this level most levels I would
think I would hope maybe but anyhow f4
on f4 night here rook f2 that leads to a
draw Bishop f3 much more of a fight
going on rook a to rook e1 Knight f5
there's still tricky ideas that black
can have notice you know I didn't
mention this yet but when f4 is played
yes it's defending the pawn but it's
also making your second rank vulnerable
not so easy for this King to help
contribute in this ending this isn't
ending the king wants to help but it's
not an F pawn around it's not easy for
that King to get quick access towards
the center of the board some downside
related to f4 gives up III weakens the
second-ranked white gets on with keeping
the structure as is gives this pawn up
he's fine with giving that guy up he's
going after the
horn a pawn black throws in a check
Bishop has to block and now h5 why is
black not just hanging on to this pawn
like with rook here well there's the
move Bishop d3 and what are you going to
do now this Knight is hit if he moves
you drop your rook so this cannot be
maintained in other words this defense
of a7 indirectly cannot be maintained on
King f8 this can be completely
simplified by taking out the knight not
taking the rook just yet but instead
recognizing the rook isn't you know even
threatening to take me because I will be
cleaning very quickly now I could get my
King working and if you try to creep
over like this now I'm in a position to
exchange rooks and then win this King
and pawn ending these are glaring
weaknesses double isolated pawns and
isolated pawns and white has many tempi
in his back pocket to eventually force
the opposition force a position where he
will have a one King and pawn ending let
me just highlight one of them let's say
King e6 he could play h4 King f6f-3 and
finally he has to go one way or the
other and he's now going to be
outflanked King here King e5 this guy is
going to be one soon f6 here and soon
these guys drop okay so the short story
the King and pawn endings alone if it's
stripped to just King and pawns
it's a definite white or a definite win
for white so you cannot allow that to
allow the position to simplify it's just
too easy
takes a h3 looks a little bit scary
these pieces are kind of stuck here
there's no Bishop move or good king move
let's see you want to run into a mate in
one let's see how white manages this he
stops Knight d4 Knight f3 ideas
is the way to get pushing gifts behind
the pond and now we have g4 it's a
matter of technique here I guess
white saw a clear path to victory he
went with g4 of course I I see this game
I review this game with the computer and
I see the suggestions the top suggestion
is a7 I tend to like this is an idea and
you know g4f for next grab the pun and
then get the bishop back to g2 it's you
know how Reis lice it it's still white
wind this is just a matter of technique
Carlson is choosing is g4 first and then
rook d3 scooping up this pesky h3 pawn
there is no time for the moment it
interferes with the coordination in a6
but there's no time to take on a6 for
two reasons in fact both rook takes pawn
and rook check this one being the better
one is going to win material Brooke is
now picked up but in any case rip d3
well white went with the line rook d3
instead of a 7 and we had follow-ups of
Knight g2 rook takes pawn white is now
up to pawns and just a super pond right
here
he's restricting the rook the bishop
send a pin but I mean it's like it's
like a connected past pun it's like one
pawn is watching over another it's just
a fantastic bishop in this case so
anchoring the knight on f4 after rook b3
there's already at this point that black
threw in the towel just to clear things
up a little bit how might this game have
continued at this point let's say King
g7 f3 giving the King a little bit of
space just looking to move towards the
center 96 King F 2
you know just getting the pieces
involved rook b7 looking for this and
then well actually
the rook on d6 is quite a strong piece
here rook on d6 is
strong piece why exactly well after King
f6 you could improve like this where
let's say there's a check thrown in let
me just highlight this one idea King III
by keeping the rook on the sixth rank
and this Bishop trained on the pond or
let's just say the a six square these
pawns here these base pawns the f3 pawn
and the pawn on h2 they are indirectly
defended so in other words taking like
this is no good because white can push
right away and after rook a to there's
this interference move of rook to a6
this would even pop up in situations
where the knight was on the c5 square
for example let's just say instead of
King f6 let's say Knight was playing
here and we had something like this
where the rook played here let's just
say the bishop played not to that square
but rather b5 this pawn this h2 pawn
these pawns over here are again
indirectly defended because white can
still push through on a7 rook a 2 there
is rook a 6 interfering with the rook
seeing that a 8 square so this is just
too much again two pawns down the white
king approaching and eventually there
well there's just no way to really stop
the King from approaching this prawn and
helping to escort him to the promotion
square there might even be ideas of
having the rook plate to the seventh
rank defend the pawn on a7 and then get
maneuver the bishop around to this main
diagonal where finally the pawn can push
through to Queen so black had enough at
this point there's really no hope no
tricky stuff against the white King and
well yeah that's pretty much it to pawn
Plus playing against Carlsen fantastic
technique there's no need to go any
further at this point so interesting
game again early on the move 7 Queen c7
not the only approach maybe you took a
little bit of way from
seeing the different position types that
you could go down the different paths
you can choose different roads you could
the different roads that you can go down
and what more the that Queen that
mysterious at her for me at least that
mysterious Queen d3 move that was that
was a little bit deep for me I I had to
really had to really think that one
through around what point here Queen D
three right here Queen D three it took a
while to really make sense of this you
know you had that moment to take the
pawn but it allowed it would allow white
to get their pieces organized defend
their their one vulnerable point that
point that pawn on f2 and then slowly
steadily improve the position of their
pieces and then when well-coordinated
when f2 has already been defended
secured you could start to think about
okay how can I attack this vulnerable
king who has you know the f6 squared the
h6 squared the diagonal there without
the dark square Bishop how to exploit
the vulnerable King so I found that in
for me personally I found that very
instructive maybe you did as well
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now
take care back and after Bishop d2
Grisha played Bishop e7 and to
everyone's surprise stood up giggled a
little bit and said aha I've
inconvenienced your queen Bishop of
course did not happen